Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
So worldwide, more than 6 million children
died in 2013, which is horrible and unjust
and unacceptable.
But it's also the lowest that number has been
in quite a while, even though the world population
has like steadily increased.
Like, Hank, when do you think the last time
was that the world saw fewer than 6.3 million
children die in a year: 1975, when the population
of the world was 4 billion?
1900 when it was 1.6 billion?
No, in 1900 probably more than 8 million children
died.
Earth has not seen a year with so few child
deaths in hundreds of years--maybe a thousand
years!
So, Hank, I'm a big fan of the Gates Foundation,
the organization set up by Bill and Melinda
Gates that is--favorite mission statement
ever-- devoted to the idea that all people
deserve the chance to live a healthy and productive
life.
And Bill and Melinda just released this fascinating
letter highlighting three myths about development--and
yes, I can call them Bill and Melinda.
Perhaps you're not familiar with the rule
of twitter following (which I just made up)
whereby you can call anyone you follow on
twitter by their first name.
See also my acquaintances Barack, Beyonce,
and Ellen.
Right, but anyway, Bill and Melinda's three
myths:
First, it is not true that poor countries
will forever be poor.
Hank, I hear this all the time, especially
about Africa, that despite their rich natural
resources, "those countries" are just "doomed"
to stay poor.
Well yeah, no.
I mean, for one thing, seven of the ten fastest
growing economies of the last five years are
in Africa.
To quote Bill, "You should look skeptically
at anyone who treats an entire continent as
an undifferentiated mass of poverty and disease."
It is not fair that Bill Gates gets to be
both a billionaire and a good writer.
Okay, it's time to put aside personal jealousy
and return to statistics.
Adjusted for inflation, Botswana's income
per person in 1960 was $383-it is now $12,000:
$48,000 for a family of four.
Now that's an extreme example, but this is
happening around the world--in the last fifty
years, income per person in India has quadrupled;
in Brazil, it has nearly quintupled.
The second myth is that foreign aid is a waste.
Okay, quick quiz--guess what percentage of
your countries budget is spent on foreign
aid.
The answer is three percent--if you're Norwegian.
In the United States it's less than one percent.
And even with that small investment, we've
seen tremendous results: twenty five years
ago, there were 350,000 new cases of polio
a year.
Today, thanks to the aid-funded polio eradication
initiative, there are fewer than 400.
Malaria, and measles, and TB have all declined
dramatically, and healthier kids go to school
more, and then they work more when they grow
up than they would if they were chronically
ill or disabled.
And the last myth is that saving lives leads
to overpopulation.
I hear this all the time and it's just not
true!
Population growth declines as infant mortality
declines.
All over the world.
It is that simple.
To quote Melinda, "We make the future sustainable
when we invest in the poor, not when we insist
upon their suffering."
BOOM!
The "boom" isn't part of the quote, that is-that
was my addition.
In short, Hank, these investments are showing
phenomenal returns, and the greatest risk
we face is abandoning our success because
we wrongly think of it as failure.
I'm gonna say it again: fewer children died
in 2013 than in any year on record.
And all this means, just to be clear, a better
world not only for those living in poverty
but also for the rest of us.
I know this is counter to a lot of what you
hear on the news, but wealthier countries
benefit when poor countries become less poor.
For one thing, there are more people on the
earth with the education and wellbeing to
make wonderful things, from paintings to smartphone
apps.
But there are also more people to buy the
stuff that we make, whether that's artificial
lips or, for example, my novel The Fault in
Our Stars.
Hank, the Brazilian edition of TFIOS is called
A Culpa E Das Estrelas--(he said, butchering
the Portuguese).
Even though I can't say the title of the book,
it's sold hundreds of copies in Brazil--it's
more popular there than in Germany or the
UK.
A country once deemed incurably poor now has,
by some measures, a healthier book publishing
landscape than many countries in Europe.
And it's not just Brazilians who benefit from
Brazil's phenomenal growth--it's also young
adult novelists in Indianapolis.
So thanks to everyone in Brazil who's bought
my book and thanks to the Gates foundation
for decreasing world suck and busting those
myths.
There's a link to Bill and Melinda's letter
in the dooblydoo; it really is worth reading.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.